[Music]
they say that tango is more than just a
dance
but if you let the spirit of tango take
you it will help you to better know
yourself and your partner embrace in
this music we can really explain without
words what we're feeling to each other
and sometimes really really deep what we
can't even describe with the words it
was developed in Buenos Aires by 19th
century immigrants mostly men dancing
with men developing their fight moves in
the rough slums of the emerging city it
grew throughout the 20th century in
popularity and respectability to become
the swirling sequined artform it is
today now danced around the world and
every year the world's best dancers
return to reacquaint themselves with the
home of tango tangos soul lives around
the world because tango is universal
which is one of the most important
things it has achieved in its history
the possibility that the whole world can
dance it the World Cup has two
categories traditional tango salon which
is improvised with the dancers not
knowing what music they'll have to work
with
and choreographed stage tango no support
of the earth on it's among the thousands
of Argentines both young and old that
the essence of tango is still alive and
thriving Luciana
learnt from her father a tango singer I
in three minutes there's a connection
between a man and a woman that takes
them from the moment the tango is danced
with the feet but it's felt in the heart
Luciana teaches classes to foreign
tourists will be guard by a dance which
has long provided the soundtrack to life
in Argentina I believe it's in our DNA
it's the way we live the way we love and
what we feel it's not to do with whether
you're a good dancer or can sing or play
an instrument it's to do with being born
here and living here they say that
everybody is able to learn tango perhaps
with some exceptions
every year tango comes home but then
here in Argentina it never really goes
away then you swine they're out to zero
when Osiris
[Music]